ja und jetzt schauen wir in die usa nach
dem amoklauf eines 18 jährigen in texas
steht die usa nämlich immer noch unter
schock der 18-jährige salvador ramos
hatte mit einem sturmgewehr 19
schulkinder und zwei lehrerinnen
erschossen bevor er selbst von den
sicherheitskräften erschossen wurde und
nun kommen auch immer mehr schockierende
hintergründe ans licht so hat der 18
jährige schütze nämlich vorher ganz
brisante instagram nachrichten
geschrieben
ich dir jetzt eine grundschule zu
erschießen das schreibt der amokläufer
salvador ramos einem mädchen in einem
chat die empfängerin der nachricht eine
15 jährige schülerin in frankfurt im
messenger von facebook schreibt er ihr
ich verrate dir was wenige minuten vor
seiner bluttat
ich warte auf diese [ __ ] ich werde
ihr etwas antun
sie ist am telefon wegen eines
handyvertrags sie ist nervig dass ich
habe gerade meine oma in den kopf
geschossen jetzt gehe ich grundschüler
erschießen die 15-jährige antwortet
darauf nur ich habe eben die nachricht
hin gesehen laut cnn lernten sich der
amokläufer und die schülerin am 9 mai im
internet über ein soziales netzwerk
kennen hatten mehrere wochen kontakt
telefonierten täglich per facetime
miteinander laut der schülerin wollte
der attentäter sie sogar in deutschland
besuchen doch nicht nur ihr schrieb der
amokläufer anscheinend zufällig schreibt
er einer anderen frau auf instagram zwei
wochen vor der tat verlinkt er sie auf
einem post auf dem zwei
schnellfeuergewehre zu sehen sollte was
haben deine waffen mit mir zu tun fragt
sie ihn inzwischen hat sie den
tatverlauf veröffentlicht die post ist
du meine waffen bilder fragt der
attentäter was haben deine waffen mit
mir zu tun ich wollte dich einfach
verlinken antwortet ramos und dann kurz
vor seinem amoklauf schreibt er ich bin
kurz davor was kurz davor was guten
morgen ich sage es dir vor 11 uhr guten
morgen guten morgen was ich schreibe dir
in einer stunde okay aber du musst
antworten als die junge frau etwas
später auf diese forderung antwortet
reagiert ramos nicht mehr hat offenbar
schon mit den vorbereitungen für sein
massaker begonnen nach wie vor ist ihr
schleierhaft warum der täter
ausgerechnet sie als vertrauensperson
ausgesucht hat die laut us-berichten
minderjährige frau lebt nach eigenen
angaben nicht in texas und muss nun
damit fertig werden einen massenmörder
unwissentlich bei seiner tat begleitet
zu haben
ja wirklich ihre instagram nachrichten
die anteilnahme bei der trauerfeier in
new waldi ist riesig und auch
schauspielerin megan makel war dort sie
trauert um die vielen opfer dieses
amoklaufs in der grundschule die frau
von prinz harry legte wie wir hier sehen
weiße rosen nieder und zeigte so ihre
anteilnahme an der horror tat
und dass das sind bilder von den
tatwaffen unglaublich dass ein
18-jähriger diese dinge einfach kaufen
konnte rund 2500 euro hat der schütze
für diese hochmoderne wie sie bezahlt an
einen online shop wo er die tat war für
wenige tage vor seinem amoklauf an
seinem achtzehnten geburtstag gekauft
haben soll und besonders makaber der
online-händler wirkt auf seiner seite
für diese tödliche ware mit fotos von
kleinkindern und waffen wirklich irre
das kann man sich hier in deutschland
gar nicht vorstellen ja und trotz der
vielen toten die waffenlobby zeigt sich
dennoch unbeeindruckt während eltern in
wall die die begräbnisse ihrer
schulkinder vorbereiten kommt die
ennahdha zu ihrem jahrestreffen zusammen
ausgerechnet im texanischen houston
tausende anhänger des unbegrenzten
waffen zugangs werden hier im georgia
brown convention center zu beginn dieses
spektakels erwartet aber auch zahlreiche
gegner die sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind
dort entsprechend hoch drei tage nach
dem schulmassaker ist das timing dieser
echo für viele fast unerträglich es gab
rufe nach einer absage doch die 150
jahre alte waffen vereinigung blieb
total unbeirrt hauptredner am ersten tag
ist übrigens ex präsident donald trump
das tolle daran ist dass ich mit meinem
vater jedes jahr hierher kommen seit
1994 ach nein seit 1997 ich komme
hierhin um die werte unserer
verfassungsrechte zu feiern
es ist etwas das wir seit jahren tun
normalerweise komme ich hier mit zehn
männern vorbei jedes jahr es ist so ein
männer ding
[Musik]
was gefällt ihnen am besten
die waffen
ich bin hier um gegen die veranstaltung
protestieren wir brauchen waffengesetze
und hintergrund check es gibt so viel zu
tun texas liebt waffen aber wie viele
kinder müssen noch sterben wir müssen
kämpfen unsere babys sterben
ich habe 30 bis 40 waffen zu hause
niemand will dass unsere kinder
erschossen werden aber das event zu
canceln würde nichts daran ändern
es war eine tragödie die schlechten
menschen werden aber immer an die waffen
herankommen und ich finde dass sie den
guten menschen die waffen wegnehmen
ich finde wir sollten unsere kinder am
allermeisten schützen
wir beschützen unsere banken durch
polizisten und andere wenn wir unser
geld beschützen können warum können wir
nicht unsere kinder beschützt
diese diese sturmgewehr diese waffen
sind sehr populär und sie werden auch
haiming natürlich ist extrem mag aber
wie gesagt drei tage nach dem massaker
von oval die werden hier
55.000 menschen in des convention center
in houston hinein marschieren und es
geht gleich los mit einem ersten
höhepunkt heute am nachmittag mit ex
präsidenten donald trump der eine rede
halten wird er ließ sich nicht abbringen
davon es gibt natürlich hier in houston
und vielen teilen von texas bitten und
appelle man hat versucht diese
konvention noch zu verhindern man hat
was gefehlt eigentlich sagt auch diese
veranstaltung ab die nrw zeigte sich
hier wirklich nicht kooperationsfähig
und hat gesagt wir ziehen diese
convention durch und das natürlich ist
wirklich wie öl ins feuer in diese
extreme pasok partei die hier in amerika
tobt und man wird jetzt sehen wie diese
veranstaltung über die bühne gehen kann
deswegen natürlich auch extrem viele
demonstrationen angesagt in wenigen
stunden werden hier wahrscheinlich
tausende waffen gegner erwartet und man
befürchte dass es hier möglicherweise
auch zu zusammenstößen kommen könnte mit
mitglieder perrey dieser mächtigen
waffenlobby er herbert man kann sich
vorstellen die stimmung bei diesen
waffen gegnern ist total aufgeheizt wie
es denn die stimmung bei den waffen fans
weil es kommen ja auch wirklich tausende
menschen um sich dort eben über waffen
zu informieren weil sie ebenso viel
interesse daran haben
die anhänger dieser des unbeschränkten
zugang zu waffen bleiben bei ihren
argumenten sie sagen dass erstens dass
es das recht gebe waffen zu tragen in
amerika zweitens dass waffen eigentlich
die lage sicherer machen würden denn man
hätte einfach bewaffnete bürger die sich
gegen
verbrecher oder amokläufer zu wehr
setzen könnten all das natürlich wieder
sprachen von den statistiken amerika hat
tatsächlich die höchste zahl mit abstand
vor allen anderen ländern bezüglich der
waffengewalt man muss sich vorstellen
dass die führen dazu noch die größte
todesursache für kinder für jugendliche
in den usa der tod durch waffengewalt
ist 4500
minderjährige kommen pro jahr ums leben
bei vorfällen mit schusswaffen das liegt
bereits vor verkehrsunfällen
mittlerweile man sieht ja ganz deutlich
dass die statistik eine klare sprache
spricht aber die waffengegner lassen
sich nicht abhalten waffen befürworter
aber durch sagen lassen sich nicht
abhalten sie bleiben bei ihren
argumenten das einfach das recht auf
waffenbesitz ein in der verfassung
verankertes ist und dass eben der besitz
von waffen wichtig ist für sie für die
menschen in amerika die diese mit diesem
hobby nachgehen ja wirklich ihre zahlen
dass es mehr kinder mehr tote kinder
durch waffen als durch verkehrsunfälle
gibt es kann man sich hier gar nicht
vorstellen vielen dank herbert
bauernebel live für uns aus houston